[Musique]
notre invité politique ce matin c'était
un grise et bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos ministre
délégué chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane
vernet bonjour stéphane bonjour qui
dirige le bureau parisien du journal
ouest france
on commence par la montagne et le
couperet qui est donc tombée hier soir
les remontées mécaniques ne rouvriront
pas pour le mois de février pas de date
de réouverture annoncée par le
gouvernement est ce que vous dites ce
matin clairement c'est une saison
blanche pour les professionnels de la
montagne
je pense qu'il faut se rendre la réalité
aujourd'hui telle qu'elle est nous avons
eu hier avec le premier ministre une
réunion avec les différents acteurs de
la montagne pour regarder avec ces
acteurs de quelle manière nous allons
les accompagner parce que je pense qu'on
n'a pas la possibilité aujourd'hui de
donner une visibilité suffisante pour
leur permettre d'espérer de rouvrir en
tout cas pour les vacances de février et
ni pour après on peut pas aujourd'hui
donnez vraiment d'informations mais pour
l'instant la tendance est plutôt
négative et qui était en marche
qu'est-ce qui s'est dégagé au cours de
cette réunion quels sont les
accompagnements exceptionnelle que vous
pouvez mettre ou si vous pouvez être en
plus pour les soutenir
tout d'abord vous avez raison de dire
savez exceptionnel parce que que ça soit
pour les remontées mécaniques pour
lequel on a négocié avec l'europe une
indisposition tout à fait particulière
que ça soit pour les moniteurs du ski
que ça soit pour l'ensemble des
commerces y compris dans la vallée qui
vont être concernés par les fermetures
que ce soit même pour les industriels du
secteur du ski fait c'est l'ensemble de
la celle en sciences en écosystème voilà
la leçon de l'écosystème à qui est
concerné
derrière il ya eu des demandes
nombreuses justifier des acteurs de la
montagne et premier ministre nous a
demandé de continuer d'affiner les
dispositifs pour qu'au bout du compte
même si j'ai bien conscience que c'est
toujours un arracheur pour tout le monde
pas ou pas ouvrir pas travailler on
essaye au maximum de compenser les
difficultés financières est ce qu'il ya
des angles morts des trous dans la
raquette comment on fait pour penser à
tout parce que finalement vous avez
aussi les communes qui elle même et
enfin en cascade tout le monde ait
d'impact et oui il ya eu par exemple le
syndicat des moniteurs de ski enfin il
est possible de poser des solutions pour
tous on va trouver les solutions pour
tout ce qu'on le fait est bonne le maire
remercie dans les autres secteurs
économiques
et qu'est ce qui vous pose le plus de
problème par rapport aux acteurs de la
filière non on peut pas dire qu'il ya
des problèmes on dira qu'elle est où ici
physique est bon et c'est naturellement
c'est la fonction qui a été la mienne et
que sur lequel le pr nice me demande de
travailler au fur et à mesure qu'un
acteur nous dit ben voilà vous avez
oublié telle ou telle mesure tel ou tel
acteur nous regardons comment dans les
dispositifs existants ou s'il faut les
étendre on peut trouver des solutions
mais comment on fait par exemple que la
montagne c'est beaucoup de saisonniers
comment on fait pour indemniser ces
saisonniers qui ont un statut très
particulier finalement les avais le
borgne a déjà indiqué depuis plusieurs
semaines que pour les saisonniers
il y aurait une prise en charge qui va
de prise en compte leur après et elle
tuera moyenne la durée qui leur permet
après la saison de pouvoir bénéficier
des droits
donc nous avons gardé salle et isabelle
borne et est mobilisée là dessus et les
saisonniers ont fait partie des
priorités depuis le début on a aussi les
résidences hôtelières qui sont concernés
enfin voilà on l'a montré un écosystème
qui est très riche en diversité on a la
chance d'avoir des acteurs qui sont très
mobilisés qu'ils soient même dès qu'ils
font des propositions et donc on a un
travail que je considère comme très
constructif et parce qu' est-ce que vous
irez jusqu'au indemnisé par exemple des
propriétaires d'appartements qui ont
l'habitude de louer pendant la saison et
qui pourront pas cette année parce qu'il
ya pas de ya pas de saison mais ce que
j'évoquais les résidences hôtelières il
en service non mais même les
particuliers sous les particuliers vont
toucher les loyers en réalité parce que
non mais ce que veut le
le dispositif les propriétaires ont les
appartements qui leur ont garanti de
location par des structures jeu pas cité
les noms enfin il ya quatre ou cinq
grands opérateurs qui assure les loyers
des propriétaires et donc nous on est en
relation avec ces opérateurs pour
compenser l'âme le manque de recettes
qu'on soit clair alain griset le
gouvernement hier a annoncé notamment
une prise en charge des coûts fixes des
entreprises des secteurs de la montagne
concrètement qu'est ce que sont ses
coudes fixe et est ce que toutes les
entreprises sont concernées
la réponse est d'autant plus concernée
oui ensuite y'a des ailes que soit la
taille quel que soit le chiffre
d'affaires tout le monde est concerné il
n'y a pas de critères qui excluent qui
que ce soit naturellement c'est pas les
mêmes les encours fixe de remontées
mécaniques sont bien plus importants que
nos coûts fixes du commerçant de l de la
vallée mais en tout cas quelle que soit
l'activité
l'objectif du gouvernement c'est de
trouver un dispositif qui permet de
compenser ses coûts fixes
alors qu'est ce qu'il ya dans le terme
de coûts fixes citoyenne d'une
définition il ya encore avec la
commission européenne
une discussion d'ailleurs pas seulement
pour la montagne pour regarder pour par
exemple on est ce qu les coûts fixes les
amortissements les emprunts
après il est où le tout le reste d'abord
faut savoir qu'il ya une prise en charge
à 100 % de l'activité partielle il ya
exonération de cotisations sociales
et puis après les coups fils bon ben
c'est tout ce qui concerne le
fonctionnement classique d'une
entreprise et les loyers sont
naturellement sans aucun doute il ya
également les coûts d'électricité enfin
bon voilà des coûts d'une entreprise
et on fait lice à chaque fois et le
remontées mécaniques et des coûts fixes
plus importante
donc on prend en disposition et on a
obtenu de la commission européenne la
possibilité d'avoir des dispositifs
particuliers
on a encore une discussion qui peinent à
finaliser mais j'ai bon espoir que dans
les quelques jours ce sera fait
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui bloque de la
part de la commission et non ce sont
souvent des montants puisque là vous
savez le fonds de solidarité qui est un
des outils majeurs des quatre
dispositifs qu'on met en place à côté
des prêts garantis par l'état activité
partielle et cotisations sociales
nous avons commencé au mois de mars
dernier à 1500 euros par entreprise avec
des critères d'exclusion fallait pas
faire plus d'un million d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires elle peut avoir plus
de 11 salariés
là on est sont des dispositifs il ya un
dispositif à 10000 euros de compensation
de chiffre d'affaires ou 20%
jusqu'à un million d'euros au dessus
d'un million d'euros on n'arrive qu'à 3
millions de compensations possible et
dans un dispositif d'une discussion qui
permet d'aller jusqu'à 10 millions donc
voilà on a vraiment adapté en fonction
des situations fonction des besoins
aussi parce que on comprend bien et
l'objectif du président de la république
été édictées au mois de mars dernier
c'est de dire priorité aux sanitaires
c'est qu'on continue à faire mais on
essaie de maintenir le tissu économique
pourquoi parce que on n'est pas dans une
crise économique classique honda poteau
sur une crise sanitaire et l'objectif au
moment on tourne la clé de la reprise
ses complices très vite reprendre ce qui
s'est passé d'ailleurs au mois de mai
dernier pour au bout du compte le pays à
côté de la reprise aussi en profitent
pour se transformer et que la petite
lumière et en bout du tunnel la france
soit plus forte ce point économies
qu'elles étaient avant juste pour finir
sur la montagne est ce que tout a été
annoncée hier où est-ce que vous
réfléchissez à de nouvelles aides encore
pour ce secteur
nour y est on
bien identifié les demandes je vais avec
bono maire regardez encore avec les
acteurs comme on doivent finaliser les
quelques aspects qui reste encore à
finaliser mais nous serons prêts le
moment venu de façon à les accompagner
je dirais une question de quinze jours
trois semaines mais enfin finir la
coller la discussion de la commission
européenne mais enfin il ya aucun doute
qu'on indemniserait d'ailleurs même j'ai
indiqué hier que on pouvait commencer à
avoir des demandes pour payer une partie
pour que la liquidité soit disponible
assez vite parce qu'il ya aussi une
question de liquidités immédiates
oui c'est ça parce que les aides elles
ont été annoncés mais avant arriver
quand concrètement à ces professionnels
pour pour le mois de janvier
les demandes peuvent être faites très
vite mois de février et même si dans un
premier temps on n'a pas le dispositif
finalisé au de rhodes les dirigea les
les dispositions existent en leur
permettant de commencer à voir des êtres
par exemple si on n'est pas totalement
terminé les négociations sur les 10
millions la négociation serait de 100
milles et romillons se terminer on pour
aller jusque là
bon si on vous suit bien il y aura pas
de mouvement de contestation de fronde
autour des problématiques de la montagne
c'est tout et tout est géré je ne sais
pas je l'espère non mais l'annoncé
majeure non mais les élus sont là pour
nous demander clairement un
accompagnement maximum au regard de la
situation qu'ils vivent
mais je n'ai pas entendu je n'ai pas
senti nous volonté de contestation il ya
une réalité qui est là sanitaires on a
affaire des élus qui sont responsables
et qu'ils comprennent la situation qui
nous amène tout ça c'est pas de gaîté de
coeur que le président le premier
ministre dit qu'on doit fermer la
montagne on le ferme pour des raisons
claires et nettes salutaire et donc à
partir du mois nous fermons il est
normal que nous essayons de compenser et
d'accompagner alors un propos de
contestation si chez les restaurateurs
que ça se passe pas très bien il ya un
mot d'ordre national hier est ce qu'il a
est-ce qu'il a été suivie des
restaurateurs qui disaient qu'ils
allaient rouvrir leur établissement pour
la journée tout d'abord vous avez des
retours là dessus je ne crois pas
qu'il m'arrive de passer deux jours sans
avoir de réunion que les restaurateurs
c'est un secteur que nous accompagnons
beaucoup avec laquelle nous avons une
discussion régulière sur tous les sujets
et monde hier n'étaient pas fondées pour
vous comment c'est très très clairement
bon avant tout je pense
il faut que je rappelle que je comprends
très bien la difficulté intellectuelle
le psychique et morale de ceux qui
considèrent qu'il y en a marre de ne pas
travailler
voilà pour les restaurateurs l'important
c'est derrière son fourneau de 20 ses
clients et que c'est très difficile quel
que soit ce qu'on fait ce plan financier
ne pas ouvrir pour ça je comprends très
bien
par mon parcours par le fait que je
connais tous ces gens très bien je
comprends et j'accepte ce qu'ils nous
disent parce que je sens moi-même donc
ya pas des difficultés mais par ailleurs
les dispositifs qui ont été mis en place
sans commune mesure avec ce qui était
imaginé est donc très hautement je vous
dis il est inacceptable et nous
n'acceptons pas que certains brave la
règle à la règle vont à l'encontre de la
loi et les mesures seront prises bruno
le maire l'a dit hier très ferme de
fermeture administrative alors ils sont
fermés mais ça peut aller beaucoup plus
loin
et puis surtout après derrière dès qu'il
ya quelqu'un qui respecte pas cette
fermeture ça sera stoppée au fonds de
solidarité un mois la première fois et
si jamais il ya récidive ça sera stop
aux fonctions et arrêter une façon
globale des sanctions et sketches et des
sanctions parce que bruno annoncé ça
hier matin est-ce qu'il y en a eu sur
les restaurateurs qui ont ouvert hier à
d'ailleurs il n'a quasiment pas qu'ils
ont ouvert avec quelques chiffres 1 en
orient c'est lent mais c'est jédir
vraiment des quatre est un marginal bon
et hier j'étais encore avec leurs
représentants non de façon la profession
elle-même dit stop
elle allait renforcer la profession
justement pour dire il faut pas pour
dire à ses restaurants ouvrent oui c'est
très clair il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
là-dessus ait pas d'ambiguïté parce que
on travaille avec eux tous les jours je
pense qu répond vraiment à leur demande
je rappelle quand même c'est pour les
restaurateurs les plus petits en taille
c'est dix mille euros de compensation de
fil d'affaires jusqu'à un million
d'euros c'est 20% défis d'affaires
je rappelle que même demandé 15 % de
compensation de filles d'affaires en dix
ans 1 15% on arrive à couvrir les frais
nous sommes 20 % et que au delà de 1
million d'euros par mois de chiffre
d'affaires
on peut aller jusqu'à trois millions de
compensation coup plus qu'au premier
continent et c'est sans commune mesure
puisque c'était 1500 euros qu'à côté de
seuils 100 % d'activité partielle
exonérations de cotisations sociales
donc sur le plan financier très très
honnêtement je pense que nous sommes à
une situation qui permet de compenser
par contre vous êtes vous avez vous êtes
obligés de tenir le même discours que
pour la montagne
en réalité vous naviguez à vue il n'ya
aucune aucune perspective a donné aux
restaurateurs aujourd'hui vous ne savez
pas quand est-ce que les restaurants les
bars pourront ouvrir personne ne sait
très clairement non mais qui est capable
y compris dans le milieu médical de nous
dire à quel moment la situation
sanitaire sur tel qu'on pourra dire ou
vrai mais qu'est ce que vous pouvez
donner comme perspective du coup aux
restaurateurs qui n'attendent qui ne
demande qu'à pouvoir travailler en fait
mais la perspective d'abord un il ya une
perspective c'est on allie rue on a le
virus et puis on a le vaccin qui permet
de dire dès que nous serons livrés
suffisamment enfin vacciner et il y aura
un moment que j'espère le plus rapide
possible ou avec le vaccin et puis avec
le comportement des français
le pari que le président a fait en
responsabilité c'est de dire nous allons
réussir à maintenir et à diminuer le
nombre de virus par jour le nombre de
cas de dell personnes affectées par jour
et on va réussir à ne pas confiné avec
l'objectif qu'au fur à mesure ce nombre
décent et combiné avec les vaccins on va
avoir une croisement des courbes qui
nous permettra de dire voilà le jour
venu bon le président avait fixé à 5000
cas par jour au mois de décembre
on est autour de 1
vingt mille si on arrive à descendre en
dessous de 10 milles en direction de
5000 je pense que là on aura des
perspectives plus intéressantes penser
que c'est faisable c'est encore jouable
naturellement que je pensais tout à fait
faisable en dessous de dix mille vous
commencé à envisager la réouverture d'un
homme du passé mais président avait 10 à
1000 bons donc moi je reste sur ce que
président a dit mais je pense
sincèrement que entre locaux de
couvre-feu respecter vraiment au maximum
et le fait que le variant anglais ne
prennent pas le dessus
on a là un petit trou de souris un
passage qui nous permet d'espérer de
rester dans cette situation ce matin
dans le journal le parisien guillaume
pelletier quel numéro deux des
républicains proposent de créer une tva
à zéro pour son pour les restaurateurs
et les hôteliers et de transformer les
prêts garantis par l'état en fonds
propres est ce que vous y seriez
favorable la tva mais diarra plusieurs
reprises y ait eu des demandes
la réponse a toujours été très clair
nous n'avons pas pour objectif de
toucher à la tva pour une raison très
simple c'est que à un moment donné les
liens représentants qui propose ça nous
dire on m'attendait le déficit de l'état
comment vous remboursez bon la tva c'est
une des rares hausses est aujourd'hui
que l'état peut bénéficier donc il n'a
pas envisagé d'y toucher sur les prêts
et garanties par l'état
il y a sans aucun doute à un sujet sur
lequel nous travaillons déjà puisque il
ya eu 1 en différé
nous avons renégocié maintenant il ya
deux ans de différé beaucoup de
représentants juste titre nous disent
mais pourquoi devoir rembourser 25 % de
notre chiffre en quatre ans ce qui peut
paraître pour des cas certains cas
difficiles donc elle peut nullement nous
allons regarder là aussi avec la
commission européenne pour voir de
quelle manière il est possible ou pas
peut-être d'étaler les trouver des
solutions non on n'envisage pas
d'annuler cetus et à un emprunt savez
vous ne direz pas assez à ces
entrepreneurs et chefs d'entreprise
ce que vous avez emprunté je rappelle
que ces 130 milliards bon c'est pas tout
à fait anecdotique et le principe du
prêt ces cours en bourse
il ya des d'autres éléments comme le
fonds de solidarité
c'est une subvention qui donnait
exonérations de cotisations ces données
activité partielle s'est donné ça
toujours at il dit comme tel le preset
après que ce soit l'état d'ailleurs que
ce soit les entreprises lorsqu'on
emprunte on paye par contre on peut
toujours regarder les et allemand soit
c'est tout à fait possible de façon à
soulager la trésorerie des entreprises
je permettez moi aussi de préciser qu'à
côté des prêts garantis par l'état
il va y avoir les prêts participatifs
qui vont d'ailleurs être hors bilan il
ya possibilité pour ceux qui ont besoin
de fonds propres
d'avoir des avances remboursables donc
en termes de liquidité on a un ça donne
des outils pour accompagner les
entreprises
il n'y a pas un risque qu'un certain
nombre de ces prêts ne soit pas
remboursé simplement parce que les
entreprises font faillite ou est-ce
qu'on en est à ce niveau-là notamment
sur les les petites et les moyennes
entreprises
pour l'instant la pompe sur france 2 a
dit qu' à peu près 65 % des prêts qui
n'ont pas été utilisés qui n'ont pas été
utilisés mais sur les faillites
bon les entreprises qui ferment a coûté
pour l'instant sur les faillites
on a 30 % de faillite en moins en 2020
qu'on en a eu en 2019
comment vous expliquez ça c'est la force
du dispositif mis en place c'est
l'accompagnement d'état bon ce que nous
essayons sera tenue en 2021
c'est notre objectif l'objectif c'est
d'avoir des dispositifs qui permettent
d'accompagner les entreprises les plus
en difficulté la question ça s'arrêtera
pour le moment l'état est derrière ces
entreprises a été très clair une fois
que la crise sanitaire sera passée le
quoi qu'il en coûte ça sera terminé
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour ces
entreprises après alors on est dans une
logique normale de l'économie l'état
accompagne parce que il y à la crise
sanitaire et qu'il faut accompagner les
entreprises appartenu au moment où sera
dans une économie qui reprendre un
fonctionnement normal y'a pas les tabacs
leveaux n'a pas vocation à financer sans
arêtes parce que c'est l'argent public à
venir pour les petites et moyennes on se
veut dire que
il faudra qu'on va regarder ça
naturellement au quotidien on a un
modèle qui a été ponctuel mais qui peut
peut-être tout servir d'élément de
comparaison c'est ce qui s'est passé
entre le 11 mai dernier et le mois de
septembre au moment où il ya eu la
reprise la reprise a été assez dynamique
et globalement on n'a pas vu entre mai
et septembre une accélération des
défaillances
on n'a pas vu elle pas mesuré c'est du
concret c'est du vécu
donc la question est ce qu'il y aura en
2021 plus défaillant ce qu'on 2000 bahts
peut-être parce que on râle mettons
qu'on reprenne la vie économique
classique on devrait être à peu près à
50 milles défaillance nous étions à
35000 ça c'est l'étiage classiques
habituels donc on reprenne 50000 les
mythes
même si toujours dramatique une
défaillance mais d'ailleurs les
défaillances et qu'il faut des gens qui
arrêtent parce que c'est la retraite
enfin bon c'est pas toujours qu'on sera
dans les pures ici on ne vend les purs
on sera à peu près dans une année
normale
est ce qu'on aura un peu plus pour
rééquilibrer ce qui a eu en moi en 2020
c'est possible mais la moyenne est la
question c'est est-ce que la moyenne
2020 2021 à peu près sur les deux années
comme une année habituelle d'une
économie normale
c'est un des enjeux en tout cas nous
regardons les dispositifs sont très
puissantes
nous allons aussi regarder dans certains
secteurs qui vont reprendre peut-être
plus doucement par exemple
l'événementiel quand on va décider la
mise en place des congrès quelquefois
des foires des salons il est possible
qu'ils aient une durée pendant trois
mois quatre mois pendant lequel
activités nara pas tout à fait repris
peut-être qu'on regardera accompagner
ces secteurs pendant cette période là
donc il n'est pas question nature nous
de continuer à appuyer aussi fort tout
le monde mais longtemps élaborer les on
peut sur secteur
en sortie de crise est en sortie de
crise l'accompagner à peu à la fois en
diminuant pour qu'au bout du compte
chacun puisse reprendre une activité
normale
un mot sur le télétravail sur lequel le
gouvernement compte pour faire baisser
cette fameuse courbe de contamination
est ce que les petites et moyennes
entreprises jouent suffisamment le jeu
est ce que les contrôles vont être
accrus tout d'abord vous voyez bien que
toutes les activités ne pas ne
permettent pas d'avoir un taux de
télétravail identique
quand on est dans le bâtiment qui
tournait bon dans celles qui le peuvent
je pense que les petites entreprises
jouent le jeu ou si bien que les grandes
avec une peut-être une petite différence
c'est la question de la relation humaine
de l'entreprise y compris les salariés
d'ailleurs maintenant tiennent beaucoup
pouvoir garder cette relation avec leurs
collègues avec leur employeur
parce que dans une entreprise le contact
aussi le lien personnel dans l'ambiance
de l'équipe dans les projets dans
l'élaboration de la stratégie ça compte
donc quand c'est possible je pense que
comme les grandes entreprises les
petites entreprises le font mais
aujourd'hui on voit bien que l'ia y
compris même chez les salariés une
volonté 2007 est plutôt que d'avoir
uniquement de télétravail d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'a dit il avait le borgne je
pense qu'il faut qu'on trouve juste
milieu non pas de contrôles renforcés
pour les entreprises il y a eu avec les
patronats sociaux là dessus un travail
qui s'est fait il comprit que les
salariés les choses se sont passées
correctement
donc il y aura des contrôles comme
toujours il ya des contrôles mais pas
particulièrement jean ce sujet là une
question sur la fermeture des grands
centres commerciaux qui a été annoncée
vendredi est donc pour applications
mises en application dès le des samedis
soirs dès le lendemain soir suivant
est-ce que ça a été bien perçue par les
commerçants le le fait de changer de
deux stratégies notamment le fait
d'autoriser les grandes surfaces à
ouvrir tous leurs rayons contrairement à
ce qui se faisait ce qui s'est fait un
temps d'abord lorsque il y a eu
fermeture dans la grande distribution de
certains rayons c'était pour mettre à
égalité économique
le commerce de centre ville qui était
fermé mais ça n'a pas été très bien
compris surtout pas très bien vécu par
les par les clients ou les commerçants
concernés
j'avais des décisions comme celles là
ont toujours des effets qu'elle fois de
la compréhension de mécontentement était
un peu ubuesque quand même dans le dans
la chose non il y avait une volonté
d'équité traitement entre ceux qui
étaient fermés et pour avoir une équité
de traitement avec la grande
distribution qui étaient ouvertes mais
avec des rayons x est revenu dessus
c'est que ça a c'est que c'était ce
qu'il y avait des raisons aussi parce
que dans un premier temps il y avait une
fermeture en centre-ville et pas de
fermetures dans la grande distribution
donc il dit demande d'équité traitement
qui aurait été très rapidement prises là
ce que nous avons constaté
parce que c'est sa part d'un constat
c'est qu'il y avait dans les galeries
marchandes
on a vu des images on a constaté à un
moment donné vu dire des situations on
veut dire un peu le métro en heures de
pointe alors qu'on demande au théâtre au
musée aux français des conditions de
distanciation et envoyés dans les
galeries marchandes des ans les gens
serrés les uns contre les autres c'est
inacceptable bon donc abandonner notre
volonté c'est d'éviter le brassage
d'éviter de peut avoir la possibilité de
regroupement pour arrêter la diffusion
du virus
donc nous avons considéré que les
galeries marchandes les centres
commerciaux et est aujourd'hui un des
endroits dans lequel il y avait un sujet
et donc la décision a été de fermer
merci beaucoup merci à monsieur arrêtez
avec nous ce matin merci stéphane on
regarde la une d'ouest france attaque
informatique un fléau pour les
entreprises
c'était la une de votre journal sur
internet si stéphane à demain on passe
au dessus du taux au club des
territoires la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux
présente le club des territoires angie
acteurs engagés dans la transition zéro
carbone des régions vous présente le
club des territoires
[Musique]
la plaie